hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
zweier interest pickel
hier denkt euch jetzt wo es interessiert
uns
aber wir fangen mit dem video
ihr seht schon ja eingebildet wir
spielen akinator und so habe ich mir
gedacht ich versuche jetzt verschiedene
youtuber hier zu suchen und wenn ich das
nach zehn fragen allerdings soll ich hin
gekriegt hab ich mir selber eine
klatschen und warum hab ich mir jetzt
schon eine geklatscht er erst die
youtuber die wir heute suchen werden ist
kommt rafter super cooler typ wurde
deine figur youtube bekannt ja definitiv
spielt die figur minecraft ich in
letzter zeit auf heute sucht man sich
minecraft kommen ich lade das video ja
gerade am donnerstag hoch und eigentlich
kommen dienstags auf meinen kann hier
immer minecraft und am dienstag habe ich
in dem video gesagt ja ok
das kommt morgen minecraft gestern kam
die mannschaft heute computer keine
kraft ich lade einfach noch ein zweites
video hoch und das wird minecraft sein
ja ich spiele mein kraftfutter die
figuren kontrakt das zimmer ja definitiv
meine was für arizona man ja ich mag
arizona es ist ein fucking süßes getränk
aber etwas das hat das hat echt nichts
mit mir zu tun steht deine figur an der
spitze eines großunternehmens also
konkreter ist schon groß unternehmen bei
der figur spielt nicht beim fc frei ok
anders unter zehn fragen ja es ist kein
crafter und ich wurde fast eine million
mal gespielt ist auf jeden fall wieder
entspannen zuletzt vor vier minuten sehe
ich hier gerade die nächste news über
den heute suchen werden ist babys beauty
palace warum die bekannt ist weiß ich
auch nicht
babys beauty palace ist nicht männlich
sie ist durch youtube geworden sie ist
in einer beziehung sie hat einen freund
namens
jahren sie trägt keine brille sie spielt
nicht geil bossi ist okay eingereicht
von jasmins beauty page wahrscheinlich
dass - beauty page okay sie wurde glaube
ich genau so häufig gespielt wie ich ich
weiß nicht genau was bei mir stand aber
das schon auch irgendwas mit 700.000
also baby wir haben kopf-an-kopf-rennen
grad das ist tatsächlich leichter als
ich gedacht habe also ich habe für mich
jetzt irgendwie so sechs sieben fragen
gebraucht und sowie die auch gerade aber
die nächste news über den besuchen
werden ist apotheker bester rapper der
welt abo ist nicht weiblich er spielt
nicht minecraft ist über 18 jetzt über
eine million abonnenten hat der tattoos
megawatt weiß ich auf dieser überaus
scharfen darstellung können wir sehen
dass er ein tattoo besitzt ja er hat
tattoos ich weiß nicht ob er
portugiesisch spricht man weiß wie meine
figur aussieht die keine glatze und
jetzt die neunte frage er ist kein
asiate leb deine figur im wald nein okay
okay meine figur trägt rote kleidung
ausgeprägte muskeln new york aus
brasilien ich weiß nicht japan bekannte
ihre prost ihren busen
ein schwarze haare nach 17 fragen wenn
wir ab jetzt auch erkannt apparat wurde
er 96.000 mal gespielt aber was zum fig
ist das eigentlich für ein bescheuertes
fotos davon abrät eingereicht wurde
liga ab was ich mit dir passiert denkt
ob es die nächste news über dem er heute
suchen werden ist leon moschee jetzt
irgendwie wieder videos nach león ist
männlich spielt kein minecraft erst über
18 er hat ja ich weiß gar nicht genau
deine figur schwarze haare ich weiß ja
gar nichts über denen der name deine
figur etwa an nein das ist nicht ab oder
ausländischen kurssprungs ich würde
sagen ja ehrlich keine hd videos buch
der name meiner figur finden nicht mit
es kann und jetzt die zehnte frage ist
eine figur türkischer herkunft alter ich
glaub nicht also warum brauchen wir für
euch also viele fragen ist kein asiate
ist er sie hatte die haben spricht
deutsch er ist die keine ahnung ich weiß
es nicht ich denke nicht dass er eine
professur in berlin hat albanien bin ich
mir auch nicht sicher sagen
wahrscheinlich er hat augen auf jeden
fall österreich keine ahnung erste
youtube berühmt geworden
nicht noch egal wer kommt nicht die
nächsten zehn fragen sind vorbei das
halt meine wange tut megapixel weil
jeder kekse markt macht eine figur live
hacks auf youtube wahrscheinlich nicht
ist eine dunkelhäutige bulgarien ein
drittel kürzen
leon macho macho auf 35.000 mal gespielt
alter ab und wurde dreimal so oft
gespielt
das was ihr vom video meine damen und
herren ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
wären es getan hat las like da wenn ihr
mehr aktivator volt und allgemein wenn
ihr jetzt noch dran seid dann schreib
mal ab china und in die kommentare
sehe ich halt das ihr bis zum ende koks
bedanke mich bei euch fürs zuschauen
schreibt mir mal eure sachen in die
kommentare die ich wieder hochladen soll
sowas wie akinator clever bot so
internet sache nicht sein letzter zeit
immer neuer aber ich finde halt nur
sagte nato clever bottenschein oben
findet ihr ein smiley eingeblendet wenn
ihr da drauf gehen könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren wir auf jeden fall mega
chillig weil ich dann aber dazu bekomme
und hier findet ihr
irgendein anderes video eingeblendet
vielleicht das von gestern oder so und
heute abend kommt dann voraussichtlich
noch eine voll gemeinschaft ja ich habe
erst mal die schnauze